Hello Freak bitches.
What do you think about this fight card?
Got a Fox fight tomorrow night.
We're going to come back and watch the fights after I kill a monster buck.
It's on the books folks in the cards.
I'm making a prediction.
Uh,
it's a big fight.
The main event is huge.
It's high failed.
Dos Anjos is the former UFC lightweight champ versus Tony Ferguson who is
undoubtedly without question one of the best lightweights in the world.
And the guys have been knocking on the door to a title shot for a while.
It's a really interesting fight because it highlights a real issue with MMA
right now.
Uh,
and that issues weight cutting.
I failed.
Oh,
Sandra's had a terrible weight cut for the Eddie Alvarez fight.
I'm hearing a lot of like conflicting stories,
but all of them really bad.
Now I shouldn't say conflicting,
I should say a different stories,
but of what went on when he was making wait for his fight with Eddie Alvarez.
And apparently he was in bad shape,
like really bad shape,
like barely made wait for that.
And was,
you know,
just really in physical discomfort.
And pain and just all screwed up from that weight cut.
I think weight cutting is one of the worst aspects of fighting.
I think it might be worse than the beatings he's guys take [inaudible] we don't
see it visually.
You don't see cuts in their face.
We don't see knock outs,
we don't see blood when they're cutting weight.
So we don't think of it as the same kind of damage that we do from a beating.
But I think it might be as bad if not worse.
I would say worse.
It could very well be.
And then even more worse is the fact these guys are dehydrating themselves
literally to death's door and then fighting trained killers 24 hours later.
It's unavoidable.
It's unnecessary.
I mean it's not unavoidable.
It's avoidable.
It's unnecessary and it's foolish.
I think it's one of the most foolish aspects of the,
for the sport.
And you know,
we were talking today,
uh,
with some of the guys at your camp about um,
like issues with MMA and with the new owners are going to do,
uh,
now that the UFC has been purchased and I hope they institute a program to
eliminate weight cutting.
I think it is one of the biggest problems and biggest,
it's a time bomb and it's just waiting to go off in everybody's face.
And a guy like Hofeld Dosantos who's one of the elite of the elite,
before you lost it,
Eddie Alvarez,
a lot of people including me,
were making the argument that he might be the best lightweight ever.
You look at a knocked out Benson Henderson,
he beat the shit out of Nate Diaz.
He knocked out cowboy Serone in one round.
He's a fucking monster.
I mean he's a killer.
It beat the shit out of Anthony Pettis for five rounds to win the title.
Just rolled him over,
just beat him down.
I,
you can make the argument he's one of the greatest,
certainly one of the greatest light weights of all time might be the best in
terms of like champions and the guy was so depleted from his weight cut that he
was like,
I heard he's passing out backstage.
You know,
I just,
uh,
just,
if that guy died,
what's imagine,
I mean,
God forbid,
right?
But let's imagine if a guy like that dies because of a weight cut and it has
happened the last week.
The last death in MMA was in Brazil and it was from a fighter who cut weight.
He died from weight cutting.
He didn't die from the fight itself.
I just,
I think it's a terrible thing that can be eliminated and I think that if we did,
you would see better fights.
I don't really what I'm saying,
I think how,
I mean,
someone like that that's having to cut that much,
are they really,
are you really seeing them at their best?
Absolutely.
Are Not.
There's no question about it.
I think cowboy looks way better when he's,
when he's fighting heavier,
much better.
Look how good he looks at one seven.
I think that's it.
He was always,
he's always been an elite fighter even at 55 but at one 70 he looks like a world
champion.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I'm waiting to see a title contention right there.
That way.
I think it's an old thing.
It's a thing of the day about Cyborg.
Yeah.
Cause you were telling me what she walks around at one 75.
Yeah,
she's,
and I said,
well Jack does,
she is,
how does she,
how does she cut that much?
I mean that seems like an impossibility.
She does it sheer strength of will.
George Lockhart,
who's her coach,
who's a Oh really,
really high level,
um,
nutritionist and weight cutting expert and he gets her down to that weight but
it's not pretty,
you know,
there's a video of her struggling to make one 40 the,
the weight classes in the UFC for women.
As of right now there's only two,
there is a one 15 and then there's one 35 and they've experimented with one 25
that talked about doing one 25 pound weight classes.
Um,
like a title at one 25 but as of yet it doesn't exist.
but I think honestly Cyborg is said that really her best way class classes,
even 45 what she's a champion of an invicta.
Her best way class would be 55.
Yeah,
I would say.
Yeah.
And there's other girls out there man build it and they will come,
you know,
I think 55 would be a really good women's class cause you'd almost,
you could almost have that like Mark Hunt Brock Lesnar's style.
You'd get some real just powerhouses in there that are still not too big where
they're out of shape.
But they could just,
I mean they could be like Cyborg.
I think if you built it,
you'd have people coming from other countries that you probably don't even know
about,
I think.
I think you certainly would after a few years.
And that's just an investment that I think they have to make within women's MMA
right now,
women's MMA is,
is where men's MMA was when the UFC was first purchased.
There's a lot of people don't realize,
but when the UFC bought the,
when they purchased it from the old owners,
they eliminated the 155 pound weight class because a,
they used to have a one 55 then they had a one 70 and then they had,
I think they had a middle weight and a light heavyweight and heavyweight still,
but they didn't have anything lower than one 70 so a lot of guys either left the
UFC to fight in other organizations or they moved up to one 70 and competed at
one 70 and some guys were like really oversized or undersized for that weight
class.
So
that's not enough.
Obviously,
you mean that it's really important that for a guy like mighty mouse,
like if there wasn't a 125 pound weight class,
which were mighty mouse competes,
we wouldn't be able to see the best fighter of all time compete in his perfect
way class or one 35 you know,
you wouldn't be able to see Dominic Cruz compete at his optimal weight class one
45 you wouldn't be able to see Josie Aldo going that reign of terror for all
those years.
You wouldn't be able to see Conor McGregor fight at one 45 and beat Aldo and
then 55 54 for the long time,
55 which is one of the most competitive and talent rich divisions in the UFC
didn't even exist.
And you know,
so I think that the UFC,
if they really want to make that commitment for women's MMA,
they should have a full range of weight classes for those girls to compete at.
I think they should start maybe even lower than one 15 I mean you could,
you can make a real strong argument for 105 pound woman's class a one five a one
15 to one 25 and then I think really the trend of those 10 pound per weight
class that should exist,
the men's division as well,
there's two big,
the bat that gaps in the men's divisions are way too big.
There's one 70 and then there's 15 counts higher.
One 85 that's a big jump.
And then there's 20 pounds above that.
85 to two oh five 20 pounds.
Think about taking 2016 ounce t boned steaks and that's how much bigger that guy
is.
Then the guy before him,
then you go to oh five to two 65 so think about taking 60 t bone stage six zero
it's stacking up and thinking about all the horsepower that comes with all that
weight.
It just,
there's too,
the gaps are too large.
It's too few weight classes.
So I think the UFC would be,
it would be very smart for them to make more weight classes,
do a weight class every 10 pounds and eliminate the weight cutting if they
could.
And I think it can be done there.
They're probably going to have to get rid of some champions though.
Not Get rid of,
but they're going to have to re you going to have to move radio around is
around.
And the people who are just samples,
yeah,
they're not going to want to do that.
You know,
you're not going to be able to,
it's going to be a hard fight to tell a guy like Dominick Cruz,
he can't cut weight.
You know,
when he's the world champion and say,
look man,
what do you weigh?
Weigh one 55 and you're going to have to fight at one 55.